he is Emmanuel macron's fourth prime
minister but can Rishi sunak bring
political will where his predecessors
haven't talked about all right yeah
after the chat came the news from the PM
spokesperson did a deal over Channel
Crossings is in its final stages I'm
actually leaving this with renewed
confidence and optimism that working
together with our European Partners we
can make a difference grip this
challenge of illegal migration and stop
people coming illegally you ignore legal
advice but Rishi sunak was forced today
again to defend his Home Secretary we
noticed up the Urgent question wasn't in
the Commons this afternoon as her
Minister addressed concerns over
conditions at the Immigration Center in
manston the population at manston Has
Fallen
from 4 000 individuals to 1600 in the
matter of seven days that is a very
considerable achievement by the Home
Secretary by her officials in the home
office and I am proud of that
but what's happening at one Immigration
Center speaks to something much bigger
nearly 40 000 have already crossed the
channel this year four times the number
two years ago
I know how these cross-border operations
work we would work with France Upstream
to stop the smugglers in the first place
that's the discussion I would have I
hope it's the discussion that our prime
minister will have from Saturday javed's
joint action plan with the French to
pretty Patel's still grounded Rwanda
Dill there is talk now of a new deal
with France potentially even down the
line a deal with Albania but this is
something that successive Tory home
secretaries have tried and failed to fix
it certainly looked cordial and the two
leaders have agreed to keep in touch the
new prime minister knows his problems at
home will require political persuasion
abroad Ali Fortescue Sky News
Westminster